hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god hi
with me george lopez let's do the show
directly right phelps
[Music]
oh my god hi
hello everybody welcome to the first
episode of
oh my god hi the podcast every episode
is gonna be me with my co-host brian
kellen hey everybody
hey and we will be answering your fan
voicemails very important we're gonna
love those reacting to crazy real news
stories
chatting with fun guests and just
talking shop
golf music just like in life
so i'm gonna talk about whatever is
going on in my mind so if that's good
i may jump around a little bit but i
think that ultimately you're gonna enjoy
it
i know i'm gonna enjoy it more than when
i was married we're gonna jump right
into it with our first guest
the one the only ralph rox arroyo
if you ever use accent again
so rox is a a professional sports
trainer correct is that the right time
this is how you're going to be on the
show well i'm trying to make sure i i
don't
i do the thing right the idea of
watching somebody
paying somebody to watch you work out
is beyond me but yeah and they can't
like you very much right
they love your [ __ ] no but you know what
he's very effective that's what i say
is these guys that he works with all in
the
account uh two years in a row i think
world champions right
when they were the nationals you had
guys with the nationals no there was a
boston two years ago
yeah right and then uh the dodgers but i
don't have anybody with boston
and so what you do is you train guys to
either get to the level of the pros
or you get them to be at world class
level
right everybody has uh i would say two
to three percent better
performance on anything so that's what's
wrong yeah thanks for the intro
laura schlesinger man look at the thing
i do look like that boom
so what's the first segment i'm done
with that [ __ ] all right well let's get
into our next segment
actual news these are real stories
they're really weird
and they're kind of crazy stuff that's
going on out there but they are actual
real news i got a [ __ ] real news
story
about the [ __ ] boy who read so
[ __ ] boring
they left them in [ __ ] burbank he
sounds familiar
i like this one because you love guitars
and um [ __ ] you don't know what
i'd love
well i would think listen do not didn't
i just say about [ __ ] people talking
for me
oh man i'm guilty i know see now
[ __ ] look what i did well i know you
have a great collection i like this
guitarist that was a good streak he's
got it i know i didn't mean it in 30
minutes
uh this guy this guy his name is prince
midnight
is his name he's a musician i like it
already right now he's not yeah his name
is prince midnight
and uh his uncle felipe uh turned him on
a metal
he's a guitarist right so they did
guitars and stuff so he's a guitar
player
so felicia latino they are greek i
believe they're greek a greek named
felipe i believe so it uh yep
a native greece deal so
uh the the the uncle dies the uncle
donates his bones to science
or a school so they could study his you
know do use them for anatomy or whatever
they do
and then they're done with them and
they're gonna give him back the family
and
the nephew goes i'll take him you know
he didn't know to cremate him you know
to bear him i didn't know what he made a
guitar out of his [ __ ]
i have a picture i wish i could show you
he made a guitar
he made a guitar out of the bones of his
uncle a working guitar
an electric guitar that's there's
this is there's no way dude
imagine that imagine hanging that up
this is his ribs
and his hip bones and he put a neck on
it and he's sitting on an amp
that's plugged in he's playing it would
you own that though
would i own that would you would you own
that no
no way man like you're not supposed to
be [ __ ] around with your uncles
right trying to make harmonics
i don't know man i don't i don't know if
this is i don't think this is uh
you don't buy it i buy it but i i
of all the things that
is that respectful or i mean that dude's
dead but he's a metal guy turn him on
the metal so he might
sounds like he might dig it paying
homage to him
maybe that's what he said because he
turned him on to it i got turned down to
baseball i don't put him in my [ __ ]
cooler and run around dodger stadium
with him
exactly no i don't know man i don't
agree with this i i think that
um i don't know dude
it's a that's rough you look at that
picture and that's a
human being with a guitar neck sticking
out of his neck
out of his cabinet yeah up his spine if
he had a show you would never not
i mean i would be staring at that dude
all night long where's this [ __ ] eggs
get manson palooza
exactly no that's too much man you
shouldn't be able i think that's almost
like uh when somebody dies
you just can't what if you what if you
took like uh uh a
cervix and then in the middle of the
night you become [ __ ] uh
crystal the [ __ ] cervix player like a
[ __ ]
flute out of the [ __ ] you playing
spoons with the best service
[ __ ] vaginal lips all here [ __ ]
this is my favorite part
that's rough man i just i can't imagine
i don't know about a human body
he's jaw harper [ __ ] blowing air
through her [ __ ] cool
you know it's all blown out yeah
okay i thought you were playing your
grandmother's [ __ ]
dog man it's not in the right key
a little flat you know and you got to be
really good because if you suck you're
like hey man
[ __ ]
oh that's awesome you know what i mean
that's good
that's crazy that that's a little rough
sorry about that on a lighter note uh
did you guys see the video
of everybody's been showing it but the
lawyer who is the cat the cat filter was
on
and his uh zoom trial he was doing
a trial and he his he was using his
assistant's
computer to be in trial and she had the
cat filter on the whole time
so they got they have like man man uh
defendant
and then they got this guy it's a cat
and he all you see is his eyes looking
like what the [ __ ] is going on here
he couldn't get out of it and he saw i'm
not a cat like that and they're like we
know sir
they're trying to help this dude out but
i mean that's like the thing
now everything is done by zoom no matter
how important but how do you get
yourself as a cat on zoom he didn't know
because he his assistant had the cat
filter on apparently
on whatever that is that you do a cat
filter on and he couldn't get it off and
she wasn't around
so he was [ __ ] oh wow so and he kept
on saying he goes i'm not
a cat and they're like we know sir and
it's just one of those things
it's typical of these days and you hear
all the time of people thinking that the
video is
they think the video is off and it's not
and they're
they're in a bad spot but they didn't
they didn't say this this doesn't count
because you're using a filter no but no
it was legal
but it was just they couldn't stop
laughing in the courtroom they couldn't
you know it was
it like disrupted the whole thing i mean
the guy's a [ __ ] cat what about the
guy in the in the uh
in like the uh meeting uh in the town
meeting that got up and went to bathroom
and he was like
[ __ ] partying that's a great thing
and just everybody's sitting in there
like nothing you know they're saying
that
[Laughter]
your audio's on he's like she's still
[ __ ] off he's got the shirt
oh god that's awesome what's all these
other guys are doing like
there's been a couple people who got
caught i remember
years ago i was at the airport and uh
and a guy was in there
and he's in there and it's just you know
and a guy's taking a leak and dude goes
b-flat
beautiful did everybody [ __ ] lie
still i still [ __ ] remember
there's a guy in there and there's guys
with their luggage
[Laughter]
guys got [ __ ]
it's illegal to take uh to uh transport
pork
i guess over state lines and there's
this guy caught with 200 pounds
of contraband bologna oh wow right and
and and this guy went to jail wait a
minute but those are more cigar vegas
[Laughter]
but how the [ __ ] can you not take so
this guy had a ton of it like it was
business
he that was like that was his run that
was his that was his uh his east bound
and down
he hit baloney and got caught
but [ __ ] mexicans come out wrap
yourself in a [ __ ] carpet
yeah and come over but [ __ ] baloney
right
you can't oh yeah i think this is just
this is why immigration is the way it is
i'm [ __ ] bologna you can get
everywhere right in mexico home depot
exclusive it's not made of people or
it's not the [ __ ] body of the
guitar it's not a [ __ ] amplifier
that's right it's what's left of the
guitar guy it could be
i just don't i just that's ridiculous
man that
well first of all you're a health food
what's some bologna everything
everything gutted up everything yeah pig
nose
[ __ ] bologna hot dog you just grind
it up do you like them though
no you don't eat them you don't eat hot
dogs at all no
really it's been it's been years oh
really yeah but but a hot dog
is everything like it's
skin hair like yeah ligaments tendons i
think bones like when beak is in there
too right yeah whatever whatever meat
they extract from
you know the the animal all the
leftovers
they grind it up add some artificial
flavors to it and
package it up and let's go yeah
they leave nothing to waste how come
it's a [ __ ] good no
i i actually i think it's all artificial
flavoring it's put in everything you put
on top of it
you know yeah and a big old healthy
bread like a big old yeah and then you
back in that with
you know eating a dodger dog or a you
know dodger dog in the ball game and the
beer and
that's just what it is wow i i i gotta
be honest i love hot dogs yeah i love
hot dogs and they're nasty
it's just like i said it's the part of
that baseball culture whoever whoever
started that was a genius because what
about that time in new york i'm eating a
hot dog and then
you know everybody everybody's [ __ ]
business is none of their [ __ ]
business
right so i'm eating a hot dog you know
and this [ __ ] man
white dude looks at me and he goes hey
when you know how those are made you
never want to have another one
thanks and i said i know what a [ __ ]
vagina did i still eat that
[ __ ] your light's green get the [ __ ]
out of here but again like
who would [ __ ] comment like i'm
eating the [ __ ] thing and i look at
the guys looking at it yeah you want you
know how those are made
about yourself man after you bought it i
mean you have in your hand you got in
your mouth he's gonna say that to you
that's nice
unbelievable yeah yeah that's our news
hey brian so let's take a listen to what
we got in our voice
mailbox which is always very exciting
because i think that's the only time
these people that call in
are honest so now listeners have a
chance to
get us to answer their questions i would
say messages about marriage
about dating about mortality
if you have a ghost story paranormal
activity
orbs you have twinkling lights
you have sounds or bumps or if you're
laying in the mattress and trying to go
to sleep and you feel like
somebody either sits at the edge of the
bed or is moving around you
for sure call for that so listeners if
you want to take a chance
for me to answer all your questions call
in and leave a message for
oh my god hi eight one eight five three
three eighteen forty three what do we
have today
okay so here we go i'm gonna start with
the first one so i'm just going to click
on it right here we go
hi george this is rachel excited for the
new podcast
my question is what's the first concert
you went to
and what's the best concert that you've
been to
thanks bye well you know music is a
huge part of my of my life
the first concert i went to i went to
see kiss at the
fabulous farm in 1976 the ticket was 14.
i begged my grandfather for [ __ ] a
month you thought i would
was asking him for the money to buy a
house next door to us that [ __ ]
held those fourteen dollars
and i and they were gonna give it away i
remember these guys were like hey man
we're gonna give this to we're gonna
sell this ticket if you're not gonna go
and it's just this [ __ ] man
and i got i got the money i saw them in
1976.
um they were great became a kiss
freak as they called us and um
i'm gonna go into my friendship with the
dude but then the best concert i ever
saw
i'm gonna say that in 1981
when van halen who was from pasadena
headlined the forum for the first time
they were like
the fun ass
band everybody loved them no color lines
no racism and music
nothing other than just rock
and they had just van halen two had just
come out
and uh it was
from the i told you from the first
second
through the whole thing and then
david lee roth had everybody there
18 000 people yelling disco sucks or
just spontaneously
at the same time and it was
just magnetic like energetic that
it's just now you know all that [ __ ] can
be created
yeah this is just four guys pasadena
local and then he came out
with a boxer's robe like sequence black
and
and silver and they had a vh on the back
with the hood
and then he and then he took the hood
down
um and he just kind of standing there
looking out at the at the artist just
and all these people just
losing their [ __ ] minds like maybe
the loudest i've ever seen
uh a crowd be and he stood there for
what felt like forever and it was it was
just
[ __ ] incredible man owned it and it's
and it's the and it's you know you see
him
well when you see something you know
multiple times but the first
those were pretty good first and they
were what
um five years apart
yeah thank you for your uh call rachel
yeah that was it
and tons and tons of shows you know and
i think even as
you know music becomes easier to see and
on the internet and things to you know
uh watch
uh but i still would say to anybody that
anytime when this whole thing is over
that you get a chance to go and see live
music
i would say go and do that is there
another one uh yeah here uh
actually this one is uh my
just in looking these looks like my
personal favorite and it just looks
interesting so let's listen
oh my god george so it's me jesse
what's up so my birthday is actually
march 7th so if he answers that would be
awesome
i actually had a threesome with my
girl and uh the other deal that she
actually brought into the relationship
uh i would actually like them to be
together you know
and how would i actually make that go
through is that a smart idea i want to
see what you say
have you ever been in a threesome like
this like that i
who is this dude that [ __ ]
better relax hey
you ain't gonna get it if that's your
[ __ ] attitude right there you're not
gonna get
a woman to give you any kind of [ __ ]
choice
i think he's already done yeah he was
excited
well um i think his
i think his whole approach is you know
how did he say get him to do it
i think right what to do what's the move
he wanted both of them to date each
other is that what he said
he wants to see
let's play it again let's hear it okay
all right
oh my god george so it's me jesse
what's up so my birthday is actually
march 7th so if he answers that would be
awesome
i actually had a threesome with my girl
and uh the other girl that she actually
brought into the relationship
uh i would actually like them to be
together you know
and how would i actually make that go
through is that a smart idea
i want to see what you say have you ever
been in the threesome like this like
i don't know what this is this is my
question
what about the caltrans do you ever have
one go through
that is [ __ ] awesome
but listen if you're in a threesome with
two chicks and you can't get those two
to be with each other
i think they're going to hook up and
then get with me so
hey but how would you do that like let's
say let's say what advice would you
because i know you've been with with
three girls or two girls
three probably even it whatever it was
yeah it was
complicated so i i just think it's
pretty simple to get them to be together
i think if they already did the deed it
sounds like he wants them to date though
yeah
that's kind of that's what i'm saying if
they both date each other then he's
gonna be the odd man
out you're not gonna i don't know if he
wants that listen man
you're not gonna get your girlfriend
to agree to be dating another girl
and have a relationship where like
there's one guy
and then two women and then when you
have sex
you know they have they have sex with
each other
while you're there and then that just
becomes the normal part
part of your life that's that doesn't
happen
so i would say to paul ikarai
just take what you can take and be happy
with that
and do not complicate the threesome
because complicating the threesome with
you know why don't you guys eat each
other now
that wouldn't be such a bad thing it
just has to happen you can't ask yeah
right anybody want ass
i just think you just have to maybe
i don't think he just wants to the
threesome on tap
is what he wants you know i mean like
he's he wants a threesome on demand yeah
exactly
exactly i don't think the threesome um
happens
on demand it's going to happen but also
you you don't want it to be um
something that's expected either because
the beautiful thing about a threesome
is when it's unexpected and that's the
that's that reveal or hey this is gonna
happen
is what's exciting about a threesome not
you know uh like in wrestling two about
two on the other side
you know you're like oh the main event
you know it's it it has to happen
naturally and uh
putting listen you put a label on
everything it changes everything
so now wild card if you're it's wild
card so if your birthday's march 7th
maybe we'll try to get this to you by
then but um
how could i just let it happen dude
yep all right that's uh outstanding okay
we got another one right here uh
this one should be pretty
straightforward i think
hey george um oh my god hi
so yeah you're having the march first
your podcast
that's my birthday so um
yeah just wanted to say hi you're my
dad's favorite
he's back for me now but yeah
first of all happy birthday march 1st
and it's
oh my god hi you [ __ ] half-hearted
[ __ ]
it was a [ __ ] energy but you're a
young guy man
[ __ ] half heart oh my god hi you're
my dad's favorite
but probably your dad's favorite because
i got more [ __ ] energy than you right
i think he wants a [ __ ] son out there
walking around
[ __ ] mumbling around the house
[ __ ] raise that [ __ ] volume
essence
and have a good [ __ ] birthday all
right
put your own finger in your cool and let
your uncle smell it that'll get the
[ __ ] party going
oh god dig around happy birthday yeah
wait you know hey guess what so remember
when they had stag films at uh
oh yeah bachelor parties you don't
[ __ ] heard anybody my friends you
they just put them up on like a
sheet and they had this lady fingering
herself he got mad at i go hey look at
her near my
trying to find a car
ah that stuff kills me that kind of
results
hey he [ __ ] took off how to walk over
that [ __ ] seven miles i had to walk
straight down
[ __ ] uh uh what was that street
[ __ ] uh
cybernational mission that was [ __ ]
separate mission in balboa
and i lived seven i had to walk in the
just because i said hey here and there's
looking
closer i got once i got to the park i'm
like you know i'm just going to sleep in
the [ __ ] park
it took me forever to get home man it
was just for that what'd you do
[ __ ] big bush and [ __ ] [ __ ]
fumbling around i said hey
check out ernie's mom trying to find her
keys hey oh god
oh my god that is for that hilarious
seven miles oh man that's a good one and
then i got arrested for a dui
and i was in one of those uh uh police
uh
a bands that you see like the big bus
where they chain you to
another person so they went around uh
i got a i got a dui on a sunday night so
i woke up in
uh foothill and then they go around to
all of the other police departments
and collect the prisoners then they take
you to van nuys
and you get arraigned so i was connected
to another dude
there was like 40 guys in there and then
on the way to granada hills
the police station we passed that house
and of course what do i think
that's the house i tore in his mom that
you're looking for a [ __ ] car keys
digging in there [ __ ] snatching
those guys must've been dying oh come on
that's 19 years old that's gold and
chained to another guy
in a cell and um
i i i'm looking down you know
i'm looking down and these guys in
orange jumpsuits come in like we're in
our regular clothes because we were
arrested on the sunday you got to spend
the night
but the inmates these guys come from my
county jail they're in the orange
jumpsuits
with those prison you know slip-ons and
this guy comes in he's a big dude he's
got like
blonde hair and he sits next to me and i
look down and his toes are painted
right so i look down i'm looking down
like this toes are painted and the guard
comes to the door and goes lopez
and i stood up and the guy in the orange
jumpsuit stood up
and the guard says no mrs lopez
and that guy went and i sat back down
and when i got my sitcom i put that
scene
in uh in my sitcom oh smack
word for word uh
[Music]
in the time that you've been training
athletes with all the
all the guys that become pictures
they're improved
physically mentally has it made them
more durable
as athletes yeah i want to say because
you know we talked about somebody either
blowing their arm out
back in the day or or even you know if a
pitcher was in the
double a or triple a however you know
it's about throwing hard but the arm can
only
can only do so much i mean it's human
you see a lot like a tommy john surgery
but you see guys just tear their
arm and they have and once their
velocity is gone
they're they're done right you know what
what is velocity what's velocity
so velocity uh they they use a radar gun
they call it a radar gun to
to measure how fast you know you throw a
pitch from home plate i mean from the
mound to home plate
um average a few years back was like 90
90 miles an hour that was a fast pitch
now it's 95
plus guys are throwing 100 miles an hour
uh you know some people will say that
the guns are a little bit juiced meaning
they
they they are they are they yeah they
have to be
it's entertainment you know where we've
kind of transitioned into more of an
entertainment now so
a hundred is a lot sexier than 90. yeah
for sure you know so
and you're right about every guy only
has so many bullets
you know so that's another thing as you
get older you get wiser so you're like
okay why would i throw
you know 40 pitches in a bullpen which
is like practice
i'll throw 20 at quality pace and i'll
save those other 20 and those 20 will
stack up
now when it comes to arm care and and
health and all that
it has a lot to do with you know your
mechanics
has a lot to do with your preparation
not just the physical preparation but
you know how hydrated you are the
nutrition
so all these things it's not just one
thing it's just like everything else
it's very holistic
the other thing is guys don't always rev
that engine
so if they have a batter that's maybe
not as tough as another batter
you know they'll let off a little bit
and and know how to pitch them get them
out in two three pitches as opposed to
an albert pujols where okay now i'm
going to empty out the tank as they say
right so i'm going to throw him that 95
plus where another guy i'll throw him
92.93 i can get him out that way
wow that's crazy yeah how did hulu uriaz
hurt his arm the first time well we had
the surgery and he was out
yeah he uh he tore it's uh your shoulder
capsule
i guess he slightly tore that capsule
the capsule kind of came out of the
joint
so it was it's kind of a tricky surgery
where all
essentially all they did was was tighten
it up a little bit is it is that
preventable or is that just
no i mean there's a there's a couple
things that that went into that injury
um you know that the preparation
i don't think was one of them it was
really how that developed
you know from spring training on to when
he got sent down to aaa
maybe a little bit of frustration on his
part where you know he got sent down
after thinking he was going to be up in
the big league so
again there was a lot of things that
went into that injury uh he did have the
surgery
and every and it actually when the
doctor went in there
it was a lot better than what the mri
had shown so that was like the first
positive sign
and what was his mental attitude at that
point has to be pretty low and athlete
has to be like i could be done
yeah he was crushed man he was uh he was
young at that time he was still probably
21 i want to say 22.
yeah so um when you get injured no
matter what it is you're always
you know it's a setback but that being
your bread and butter
you know being his left arm throwing 97
98 miles an hour
and being touted as his big time
prospect that was a big blow to him
i remember being with him in the hotel
room and we were just having
conversations as to
you know we at this moment we don't know
why it happened but it happened for a
reason
you know he's a very faithful man so i
think at that point
um it was devastating to him and you get
all these mixed thoughts running through
your mind as is this it
but after the surgery once the doctor
told him the the news
about the injury not being as bad then
that was like the spark to kind of
trigger him
and then later on he figured out you
know the answers okay so if i'm a
pitcher
on a major league baseball team and i
have a pretty good arm
what's the succession of somebody
telling me how to pitch like let's say
i'm pitching friday
and uh i'm pitching against a team i'm
gonna do my work
but does it come down that you have to
throw harder that you have to win that
is is there is there pressure put on
somebody
from the side or is it just you going to
work and do your job and do your best
and if the team scores more runs and you
you know hold it down you win
or is there stuff in the business that
doesn't necessarily
take place on the field will it will the
pitching coach go to his hotel room
during the day
will they talk with the catcher or with
a couple coaches
and talk about how to how to pitch to
the batters
or is the guy pretty much left alone
yeah well it depends on the guy
so if the guy's more of a veteran he
knows what he's doing he has his
five-day layout like you said so if he
pitches on friday
friday's is his game day saturday will
be
a recovery day or they call it a you
know you you
uh you flush out you know the body and
all that so you prepare so
saturday's day one of the flush the
second day you get probably lower body
workout in
third day uh upper body fourth day nice
and easy and then you're back on the
on the mound the fifth day now within
that you're also working out
and then you throw a bullpen session uh
the second day after the start
okay so that's where you you know you
kind of take it nice and easy you work
on some things from that start
and there is a lot of preparation that
goes into it whether it be like you said
the pitching coach the catcher they look
at film
they'll study the team that they're
gonna pit uh play against the next time
they study the hitters they come up with
a kind of a basic plan
and how to attack them based on what the
pitcher throws i played in high school i
played against daryl strawberry in high
school
i played against john elway in baseball
one of my favorite stories by the way
i'm going to tell you this i'm going to
tell you this [ __ ] story
so i was watching
dodger dugout and bert hooton was on
and i think jerry doggett would talk to
bird hooton
and bird hooton threw a knuckle curve
and he
they showed how he held the ball and
they showed how he threw
it and they showed what it did and then
it's only like a half hour before the
dodgers
game started so i get a baseball i go in
the backyard
and i hold it like that and i throw it
and it does
what it's supposed to do it goes up and
it drops and and i was like what the f
what's that it was a sunday too because
you know the games are always on sunday
so
i was in high school so on on monday
went to baseball practice
and i pitched in little league and i did
pretty hard but i wasn't
you know great i was probably average
but with that pitch it changed
everything like i could
i could throw that thing and get dudes
out and my coach the coach was like
where'd you get that i said i was
watching dodger duggar
against the wall so
cut two my senior year were at granada
hills
there's thousands of people watching
we're playing grenada hills john elway
is on the highlanders or grenada's
highlanders
and the game is pretty tight for a team
that
sucks like us but you know but we're
from san fernando and they're in granada
hills and we're playing over there
grenada hills and i remember
they had an apartment building on
the right field side and then across
that this huge scoreboard like that wall
it said
you know home of the champions years
years here united highlanders and things
and they had a kid up there uh on a
chair
and he would put the numbers after the
thing
it was there was an electronic
scoreboard so my buddy arnold who i met
in 1973 still friends with he was
catching
and uh we call that pitch the delightful
you know they go throw the light forward
i would throw it
and it really did look [ __ ]
delightful because it would go like this
and it would drop and dudes would just
they would swing and they'd go and the
catcher you know he would catch it and
he'd always make a point in your life
like this and throw it back and i would
throw it again and the guys would go
like this and they would go
in right for a strike so it was
you know i couldn't throw fast enough to
get
john elway out but with that
i could get i could get him so so
bases are loaded it's like in the bottom
of the seventh inning
we're winning like four to two based on
loaded
and john always uh and i'm
and i'm just like you know these [ __ ]
people are watching
and you know if listen
nobody deserves i didn't deserve to be
in that in that the [ __ ] coach puts
me in there
the other end i got some dudes out
trying to hold on you know
and i throw it
the first pitch i throw it and it looks
like
it's not going to do like the minute i
throw it
i still remember it and honestly i said
i said oh this [ __ ] is not going
to do what i thought it was going to do
and it gave over and he swings at it
like
and he and he pops it into the net above
him
and i'm like holy and i even he throws
it back
and i and i i said i [ __ ] dodged i
dodged a bullet there because that would
have been it
so the next pitch i throw a fastball
inside and he and he kind of moves out
of the way and it hit it cuts inside
and i got him o2 so i got him o2
and and now everybody's like i gotta mow
two like john elway oh two bases loaded
granada hills i throw another pitch a
little bit up high
and he swings at it up high around the
eyes and he
follows it up in the thing so
then he follows another one off and and
i'm throwing kind of fastballs but i'm
trying to move him around he follows
another one off
and then i throw now i'm not throwing in
the [ __ ] delightful because
so i throw another one and now it's it's
uh
three and two and i throw a fastball
and it's kind of up high and he follows
it off again
and i throw another fastball and he
fouls it off again
and i'm getting a little bit [ __ ]
tired man so arnold calls timeout
and he comes over and uh i still
remember my
bed put the helm he put the mask up over
his eyes and he's little and he goes
delightful [ __ ] i said [ __ ] you wait he
says
[ __ ] you i'm not throwing that
[ __ ] because hey [ __ ] throw it
and ever that's what you're doing
[ __ ] hits me on the chest a [ __ ]
throw it i said no
he goes [ __ ] throw a little piggy
[ __ ] hey [ __ ]
throw it i said i'm not gonna throw it
so he gets in the thing and he [ __ ]
throws down the
thing and i go like that go no and he's
like no
throw a fastball follows it off he calls
time again he comes over he goes
[ __ ] throw it he can't he won't hit
it he's not expecting that so
who is expecting that [ __ ] i'm not i'm
not expecting it
and he follows another and this is like
that this [ __ ] has fallen off
like eight balls
like i've thrown 14 pitches to this
[ __ ] game
and i'm out there man there's all these
people there
and i said i'm gonna throw it
so but [ __ ]
i i throw it and it's beautiful and it's
out there
and it's going like this you can see it
going like this
and elway leans forward
and i think i got him but any good
baseball bat
but they lean forward their hands are
back and
it's like he's fooled and he's
and and he just goes like that
he just goes like that and this
remember in the cartoons when the ball
would have a mouth and yell
like yeah wherever that [ __ ] like leaves
the yard you're what it looks like
that [ __ ] ball is going
like a laser
not a home run it's just a massively
well-headed line drive
and where's it going to the kid in the
chair
that's changing the numbers and the kid
in the chairs changes never sees it and
he goes like this out of the way and the
chair falls
and it literally hits behind them and
all the numbers on the on the scoreboard
pop off because they're only on with a
little piece of you know things
and now they're all in the air you know
it looks like a goddamn [ __ ]
kino the [ __ ] baby like the kino
[ __ ] machine exploded [ __ ]
numbers flying everywhere and the little
kid falls eight and his [ __ ] leg
he felt like six feet his [ __ ] leg
hurts the chair
fell off and and elway's running and all
the [ __ ] guys are running in
and they're all [ __ ] high-fiving each
other and we lose
you know and and and i'm like in the in
the on the bus back like you
[ __ ]
you had a little bit of a [ __ ] delay
what you thought i threw a [ __ ]
delight for it
and uh and we went to granada hills a
couple weeks after that to a party
all of us and you know we'd get all
[ __ ] loaded
and then arnold goes hey lopez drive by
the fee away i said
what field granada hills i said
[ __ ] it's like 1 30 in the
morning
so we drive by the the
where the scoreboard is and we get out
and there
was a full moon and i go what are you
guys looking at
and you could see the dent and the
scoreboard
from where the ball hit and those dudes
were going look where it hit and you
really could see the deck
and and we were laughing so [ __ ] hard
in the street out there in the middle of
the night because that's where the ball
hit you can still see it
and every once in a while over the last
you know
year after that we'd stop by and [ __ ]
laugh i don't know why
it came out it became like a great place
to go laugh
right right there right under the thing
uh uh but to play
you know to play against guys like that
uh you know i never thought strawberry
two you know
all that monroe and you guys knew you
said you guys knew he was going
remember you knew he was like the man
they had this valley game and they
played at csun
where all the all the best players uh
in southern california played there and
elway played yeah
and uh you know he had like two home
runs
so we're all 18 years old even
everywhere
so all all my friends go there's
probably like the whole team 14 guys
and we're just we're almost like
old chicanos we're like hello
good luck in the sir leagues sir and we
check his head he goes oh thanks
he's our age a lot of guys go hey man
you're the greatest person i've ever
seen
you know ever
he's our age yeah but talk about
god-given like he was you know he ran
like john wayne he was pigeon-footed
yeah that's right and then i remember we
flew back from a tournament on with
wayne gretzky and his playing with elway
and the whole time we were talking about
the [ __ ] for delightful
because that was you it's even
[ __ ] uh i also remember you
always got me
uh yeah i think those guys always
remember that stuff what about that time
in new york
with the all-star game when we met up in
that lounge
and we asked wally bell to go with us oh
my god the umpire
yeah and uh we asked wally bell to go
with us right did he go to dinner with
us or we went to drinks with us no i
think
uh it was just drinks we went to drinks
and we and he was just sitting there by
himself
like an umpire would and we invited him
we came out had a great time with us
and then i remember when we got back
we're all hammered and he said george
you know there's another place around
the block we can go get a drink
i'm out and then he passed away that
year yeah but he told
all the other umpires of how
kind we were i was to him or we all were
to him so with the umpires i'm
you know i go see we go see him after
every game right to the world series and
stuff like that but
you know when you see a guy sitting at
the bar by himself
how great is it i see myself in the
future so hello
come by with the chicken i got you guys
but great
but great uh great guys how do you get
all those girls in
let's be honest with you what do you say
you really what do you say to him
no well it's funny you know it sounds
like a stupid question but i was i've
never been
really good with women at all
i don't have the confidence that it
takes to
to be well it's very depth it is a very
deep question though
i don't have the confidence that it
takes to initiate
and then once you get past that rocket
stage
i don't have the emotion to want to stay
connected
which is one of the reasons i prefer
to not be involved well i can halfway
agree with the one
though but he's great with women we've
talked to him i mean he's just
really cool he's like the coolest person
to meet right and he's
genuine and all that kind of stuff i get
the other stuff because it's usually his
choice to go
i'm not gonna call him i never saw a
relationship valued in my family
it wasn't my grandmother and grandfather
because uh sean i dare i say
about 10 days before my grandfather died
i guess i got an argument
at the market and my grandmother comes
in and she goes i wish he was dead
and 10 days later he died but
she said i wish i was uh dead to me
oh i wish you were dead and i'm still
here and she's been gone for [ __ ] 11
years
but but it's that kind of attitude like
imagine man like
this lady says i wish he was dead
and um forget the fact that
he died but that's what i grew up around
people saying i wish you weren't here
wish you were dead why don't you
[ __ ] drop dead kind of [ __ ] and
it's funny man cause you don't think
that that that stuff carries
through your life and i think it's
detrimental man and you know this dude
right here
is my best friend but also his
relationship is
is great and around these days like
valentine's day of the holidays it's
really hard for me because
it's been like that my whole life and
i don't think i don't i don't i don't
know if that
is ever going to be something that is
ever going to change
um for me in a place where
you know i look like i may have found my
soul mate
you know at almost 60. i watch you and
we see him with the chicks and out and
and literally i remember years ago i
said to a guy
what do you what do you say to him
there's two things so
a comedian we were in houston and the
guy says i have a couple friends coming
in this weekend for the show on saturday
they're gonna stay here he stayed in the
condo
and that's and they walk in and they're
both
really beautiful and while they're
changing and getting ready
um i look at them and we're watching
like baseball
and i said i said a man how did you how
do you get two girls
and he goes well how do you get two
girls he was a good looking dude and
they were walking out
and he says to me like he says like this
and they walk out and he goes your
neighbors aren't gonna you you're not
gonna wear that are you
and they both look and they go you don't
like what we're wearing
no i mean if that's what you're gonna
wear that's fine and they both go change
and he looks at me because that's how
you get two girls
backhanded stuff like that yeah yeah
backhanded
but you know you don't want to you don't
want to be a [ __ ] deceitful mother i
mean
no i mean i will be but no but i don't
but i don't even i don't even invest
i don't even invest in that i don't even
invest in that anymore
you know what i think is unfair is that
when you're growing up and all these
things are going to be with you for the
rest of your life that you're too young
to even know what those things
are or or too young to you know it's not
fair
it's not fair that you see something at
11 that's going to stay with you for the
rest of your life
and affect how you treat people
or um affect how you
treat women you know like
my mom was not my biological mother
was not somebody who
was um
even worthy to be a mom because not
mentally
in the right place and things like that
and
you know man i just think that those
things just
destroyed me as a kid and then it just
stayed with me as an adult
and i don't i don't think that there's
you know therapeutic this guy for 20
years
i'm not a quitter but i don't think that
there's
anything that can remove that feeling in
my heart
of the things that i saw and i and those
things
um are the things i think that have kept
me from
being a a husband when i was married
or you know a partner
even if if i was dating somebody and
that's that's
that's completely like open up and i
don't think it's latino thing you know a
lot of everything i talk about
is you think you equate it back to the
culture which i which i did because it
was easy you know made a lot of money
doing that uh in stand-up but i think
it's just
with guys too like if you see something
you know like my mom was
you know lived up in sacramento
promiscuous
and let me tell you jesse
and i remember one time these people
were trying to like
you know keep me busy outside and i went
inside and
i went in this room and i saw my mom
with this dude and
it's just nasty man and it's you're just
like people were like trying to keep me
out of the house
because that was going on and to see it
it's just i just don't think that
there's some things that are maybe too
big to overcome
that's a big one that's large i mean on
top of the
relationship you had already with that
that's a tough one so
and then you know my grandmother wasn't
my grandmother
you met my great my grandmother was she
she was all right i met her she's
awesome to me
she's really nice i don't know if i make
her out to be
the the worst i don't know but
she you know she did the best that she
i guess she could but her family was bad
and then the kids and all that stuff so
you know
as uh you know as i get older
and you see it sometimes in me where i
don't think i ever get
get down but i just think that you know
i would like to tell somebody hey you
know
you can overcome everything because you
know that's what people want to hear
when they say
you go talk to these kids you know you
can become a success
yes and you can become
a great father you know guys who are who
are actually
good fathers and happy to be married
and guys who you know
go places and treat employees bad
because it's their way of dealing with
the frustrations that they might have
at home when they can't talk to their
wife like that
they talk to waiters like that or they
talk to
people they meet like that and um
you know as you as you get as you get
one life to go around
you see some people that are really mean
man
and really mean to other people um there
was a guy at lakeside that
was a guy who was like mean to people
and
he had a heart attack out on the course
and the
ambulance was out there and they said i
said who's that and they said it's that
guy and i said
good hope that [ __ ] dies
and he didn't die that day but he died
eventually and then that that
i mean that's where i went because that
guy was a mean guy he was like not a
not a not a good dude he might have
killed himself by being so mean to
himself
but i think it's social media i think
this is a uh
no this isn't a real world man this is
not a real
those pictures aren't real those people
aren't real
their lives aren't real and you know not
everybody is meant to
have followers or not everybody is meant
to be
liked or not everybody can be driven by
you know trying to jump off your house
and [ __ ] busting your [ __ ] hip in
12 places you know
and it's just this thing where the most
superficial things
mean the most and it's counter to what's
good for
and decent for people 100 percent right
yep i knew this girl who took a picture
of her you know her nails and
in front of an audi and all this this
and that and that girl was
extremely depressed why are my pictures
getting likes
you know we're creating we're creating
life yeah
one of one of the guys that i study a
lot his name is paul check and he talks
about
the the bigger the distance between what
your life really is and what you
portray out in social media you know
the bigger the gap the bigger the
disease so if i post
you know how come you don't [ __ ]
people don't post pictures of their bank
accounts or their naked bodies
because they're not truthful to
themselves but they'll post
you know a lamborghini that's not theirs
or this filtered body
you know all molded and and waxed out
you know
yeah exactly yeah wow so so it is man
it's dangerous that this social
so would you say like women who who
become like
because of this pandemic you know for
fans only
where they're showing all the oils and
and
and you know the breasts and all that
stuff it's almost like
bait right like if you were fishing you
know
you put a worm on there you put a piece
of cheese you know
for you you put like a very good thought
in the water i'll buy it
right hey they're biting today
and i didn't really want to do you know
a podcast to
to because there's so many of them
but what i really wanted to do it for
was
to be able to either answer questions
that people had or ask those questions
like that
like are we a [ __ ] society that all
you have to do is put [ __ ] big kids
in a dm or on a [ __ ] account and
and you get a lot of followers i mean
this you know
are we driven by [ __ ] showing you
know your [ __ ] ass
and you know tits and
you know and and the way you look or
you're dancing outside of a [ __ ] car
i mean is that
it's the to me it's the law it's really
the lowest of [ __ ] values of
of decency and humanity yeah 100
there's a there's a documentary called
the social dilemma and it talks about
all that
and how all that's kind of controlled
and how it's creating just this
bad you know energy amongst humans man
it's just disconnecting us more than it
is connecting us because we're misusing
it
and we're not only just misusing it but
people are manipulating
you know how we use it they're almost
like steering us
you know it's funny because i'll look up
something on google that i'm searching
for to buy
and then all of a sudden on my instagram
feed it's on there so it's like way so
so are they trying to direct this whole
thing for me it's like no man i'm living
you know my life right yeah let me live
my puppet strings kind of guiding you
through the whole thing and that's the
same thing where it becomes addictive
for a woman to post a certain picture
and it gets a million likes and
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna do that again i want
to do that one again instead of being
you know posting some real content it's
just the worst part of humanity man i
think
is to is to spend any time
of your life to comment on someone you
don't know
because somebody showed you a picture
you know yeah that's crazy i mean isn't
it maybe
order or to take or to go in after
somebody like you know they think
somebody's going to be trending because
you
you know somebody got into somebody's
[ __ ] you know or they're
you know they got beef
[Music]
i saw john holmes at pharaoh's one time
made an ice cream
oh my god and they brought one of those
big ones you know for your birthday i
said that [ __ ] dude's dick could
[ __ ] hit the bottom
of that [ __ ] skin diver [ __ ]
marmal marathon [ __ ] ice cream
and still not even hit his pedals there
he lay it out there like a subway
sandwich every year
i did and you know what and and you
think you could hide in plain sight they
were like [ __ ] joe
the [ __ ] people that are buying that
long ass licorice remember that long
like yeah oh yeah that broke see if your
[ __ ] baby doesn't
[ __ ] longer than this [ __ ]
licorice right here right [ __ ] by the
foot
oh my gosh kids would argue with a
licorice roll that's not a foot
it's not john furrier man let's just
make a pencil mark
so people that buy [ __ ] licorice
don't get cheated
oh my god so our barrels this was before
i guess they used to put
you know kids might choke on things you
know there was a feral
rusita can you imagine if you're even
ice cream homemade was at the bottom
and he's like thank god you got [ __ ]
freezing
so hanging out your pants let's get ice
cream on it so i
on this baseball team my coach was like
uh
he was like maybe like 300 pounds
good dude and his son play on the team
this summer a little bit you know
off a little bit uh dan and we went to
farrell's
and they would bring you the silver
thing of ice cream
remember they would put it like in a
stretcher or these guys remember that
they play all the [ __ ] horns and run
around ferals and there's like
god who's that for you know running
around and it's this big tub of ice
cream but in the ice cream
there's little plastic figurines like
this like a fish
or like a fireman or like mermaids
and the mermaids didn't have tops but
they're plastic like little orange
things they were green or blue
they the ferals put it in the ice cream
i mean imagine bringing
ice cream to kids and serving it
with plastic things yeah in it
so when a kid eats an ice cream you have
to rely on the kids saying
look you know a [ __ ] dolphin you know
getting chokeables and the thing is
so true story so so
so we're all there you know and dan co
you know the the little boy
you know uh dan he's a little bit off
you know so he's eating it
and he pulls on like an orange mermaid
and he cleans the ice cream up and he's
licking her boobs
like that and the dad comes behind and
[ __ ] hits him in the back of the head
and he swallows
the thing and he's and he's [ __ ]
choking
on the plastic [ __ ] mermaid and he's
like
and and and you know back then all they
did was put your hands over your head
they go put your hands up there
and a [ __ ] mermaid is in his [ __ ]
mouth and they're like what happened
and his dad can't believe that because
he slapped him he swallowed the [ __ ]
mermaid
and we're like he's choking on a mermaid
and how [ __ ] stupid does that sound
your [ __ ] kids are on the table and
he's all [ __ ] red his bucket eyes are
in
his [ __ ] ears are like colors [ __ ]
and he it's [ __ ] cyber you can see it
on the [ __ ]
he's like
and [ __ ] choking how stupid are
doesn't sound you know he's like he's
choking on a fish and all the [ __ ]
kids like it's a [ __ ] mermaid
and he's he's [ __ ] dying and before
the heimlich they [ __ ] just
[ __ ] hauled him upside down
oh god i don't even think i told you
this
in the in the early 2000s when people
would ask me
you know have a certain aspect or you
know doing different interviews
you know how did you know when you made
it you know
what at what point did you say you know
i made it
so in doing my in doing my television
show
uh the prop guy um bobby
great guy comes over to me and he goes
hey man i got a call from this
girl uh who's a who's a
a prop person on a porn movie
because you know you know the poor movie
what are they what are they like
uh what props would they need
uh a chair i guess so yeah yeah
a pool sweep uh yeah so so
he says uh this girl asked me
you know can you help me make this prop
for this movie they're doing a movie
that's like uh
a radar like a like they need like a
laser gun
that shoots mecca like a laser gun
and he needs to look you know they're
doing they're doing us like a sci-fi
porno movie
and um they're shooting it on sunday
at an old hospital in boyle heights
so on friday he says to me you know
call me chief hey chief you want to go
over here to this thing on on sunday
and i said why would i want to go to see
a [ __ ] porno movie being made
and then he told me who it was which i
won't
say the name can i say the name and you
guys will block it or should i not say
the name
i don't want to say that i don't want
the name to be known
okay so but it is
it is at that time if not maybe
one of the top five
porn stars of all time
oh man so when he says the name i said
oh [ __ ] um i think
yeah i think i'm i think i i think i
will go with you
so we go and i'm standing in the
background and they're still
filming and there's a guy
that you recognize from the movies
uh and i'm like
oh [ __ ] that is that [ __ ] uh
tom byron he's so so
thrilled you know and then uh john does
that john doe
so i'm looking and and
then i see the
the porno actress the top five
and i'm like
whoa and then you know i i back up
further into the dark you know i'm back
in the corner like this like you know
and they're going through the because it
is a business so it's a business you
know they went through the business
and then they're done with that thing
and she's there and she's doing
something on her own and then
she i guess she hears that i'm there and
she has this
instrument that she's using on herself
and she sees me and she says
hey george lopez why are you crying and
she's
as she's oh as she's doing this she's
going
because that chocolate bunny why are you
crying and she's reciting
my material with this thing inside of
her as
i'm standing there and when people ask
me at what point did you
know you made it that was the point that
i realized
that i had made it how do you react
you're like yeah well i would i wouldn't
know how to react she's
she's going let me tell you the [ __ ]
inside of my underwear
it looked like somebody shot a jurgen's
bottle oh my god
oh my god you made it i think uh
being addicted my addicted to the point
is i think it's i think it's bad
i think it's you know i think it porn in
general
yeah man i think and not because ted
bundy said so
because that's what he said started him
on it but i just think that
you know and and i've looked at a lot of
it
and i you know i'm not connected to
people
like and i think that that i'm going to
say that
that i think it's detrimental to
a mind if there had been internet porn
when i was 11 or in my roughest time
like 10
i probably would have [ __ ] my
grandmother in the sleep i'm just
kidding
episode one oh my god hi
i think that's it listen everybody
thanks for listening to all your friends
wherever you get a podcast
apple spotify wherever you know bad news
travels fast
so tell everybody and um we appreciate
you spending your time with us
and i love the fact that uh this is
really kind of a fun thing to do
and i get to hang out with you i hang
out with all the time but more
importantly
i appreciate you guys for checking me
out and it's been a lot of fun
and we hope that you like it it's fun
for us and thanks for spending time with
us
brian kellen who i call you super i
don't even think i call you brian super
yeah
i love you man i love you man and uh and
keep those voicemails going the number
is
three and [ __ ] 818-533-1843 i
appreciate you brother around thanks so
much thank you
thank you for sharing all that stuff but
also thank you for being a good friend
to me
um for all these years and will continue
to be a good friend you know i love you
man i love you yes sir
brother thank you so thank you everybody
for listening to oh my god hi
on all things
you